ومن جانبها قالت وزيره الدوله للتعاون
الدولي في الخارجيه القطريه لولو الخاطر
ان قطر ستواصل جسرها الجوي للمساعدات رغم
شح وصولها للقطاع واضافت ان قطر ستواصل
ايضا جهودها لكسر العقاب الجماعيه
المفروضه
والجائر على قطاع غزه من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي جسر الجوي الذي اطلقته دوله
قطر كان قد انطلق في الس 16 عشر من اكتوبر
اليوم وصلت دوله قطر الى ما يعادل
290 طن من المساعدات مساعدات طبيه
ومساعدات غذائيه بالاضافه الى مساعدات
متعلقه بال الاواء مثل الخيم الحقيقه ان
هناك حزمه من الرسائل التي اردنا التاكيد
عليها وذكرناها للجانب البريطاني وهي ان
ما يصل من مساعدات اليوم الى قطاع غزه لا
يرقى الى المطلوب نظرا الى الاحتياجات
المتزايده نحن نتحدث عن اربعه ال 6% فقط
من احتياجات الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق في
غزه وهذا امر غير مقبول هذا بالاضافه الى
نقطه في غايه الاهميه وهي ان المساعدات
الانسانيه لا يمكن ان تكون بديلا ابدا عن
الوقت الفوري والدائم لاطلاق النار وللحرب
القائمه على قطاع
غزه